hello everyone i'm alan welcome to my
channel today i am playing
ooblets i've already spoken about this
game in a couple of videos we did a
stream on inside gaming i find this game
to be absolutely adorable and super
pleasant you will already know that if
you've seen
that content but today i've actually
partnered with epic games to bring you
the sublets video
the game is currently available on the
epic game store there is a link
in the description that you can use to
download ooblets but otherwise we're
going to jump
right into it i'm actually going to go a
new game
um maybe i shouldn't i got so far
no i'm doing it it's fine uh big tibi
goth go
brilliant i can't type the l done it
i feel like i'm probably more that color
but we do have this real problem
where listen okay
people on the internet make fun of me
for being really pale
i'm actually not it is just
the lighting setup that i have i
actually love the gray hair is one of
the staple options
i'm ready
nope nope but never that is basically
how i dress let's do it
big tabby goth go let's go so this game
for anyone who doesn't know is like
uh i would describe it as for the record
they have not asked me to say any of
this so i
this may not be their messaging in any
way whatsoever i'm just saying
maybe i need to move so i think i need
to probably move my webcam
over here let's try that
it's like stardew valley mixed with
pokemon
a little which um naturally sounds like
the most perfect thing ever
the literal beginning of this game is
about my life being a giant fart
so it's more or less what you
are you signing up for here
[Music]
hello
[Music]
it's true i am big tibi gothka from
acro island
so basically right now i moved to a new
town
that's what's up
who are you what are you doing walking
around back there you weird dude
i shouldn't even be dancing here the
music gets better
what seriously what is are you stalking
me so yeah this is the mayor she's
giving me a free house and also negging
me because i guess i don't have ooblets
which are basically like
what do you get
what are you doing uh so basically this
place's version of pokemon oobleck clubs
are the kind of ublets you have
it's really actually just your starting
oblique which the last time i picked the
nerd one let's pick a different one
go home talk to eight people that i
don't know
that is my literal biggest nightmare i'm
gonna talk to you so that you stop
stalking me okay can we talk
oh she wants me nice look at this dog
a cool fanny pack nerd is your name
literally mead your number what is that
i am living in the middle of my house i
mean i run the little gardening shop
here so i guess we'll be seeing a lot of
each other i feel a little bit bad about
calling a grandma a doc maybe i
shouldn't have done that
all right i don't know that i want to
talk to you
can i talk to anyone else first ragnolia
ragnolia operates the learnery is that a
real word which serves a variety purpose
is too complicated to get into right now
wonderful okay you're going to be
sticking around you should have this
this game has so many like cute weird
names for things they uh have a very
consistent style i'm into it
science and magic and junk you'll figure
it all out all you want i have no metric
for your aptitude for these sorts of
things wonderful thanks for having faith
in me
rugnolia so i guess the thing she just
gave me is like basically the menu
wishes
oh oh he's cute i hate that a little bit
you could have just said friends that
would be fine also i don't know that
just meeting someone immediately makes
them a friend
that seems like some social awkwardness
going on trying to talk to anyone but
this
weird human excuse me hello sir i would
like to talk to you
apparently that's how i make friends oh
well
that one's not off to a great start dude
look at his sweater though i would 100
wear that
it's like sweet pastel yeah i'd wear the
hell out of that
oh my god in the blue mustache charles
i think i love you he makes clothes
dude can i dress like you oh check out
this cool sparkly seat
what's going on with this then
nope can't interact with it great i'll
be back for you
i'll be back for you any minute now body
seat just you watch
okay
[Music]
hello double bean juice pressy
okay i just told you i don't have any
money and you sass me like that
all right double i believe bean juice is
referring to coffee
i am going to say this game is maybe
like
a little bit too cute for me i really
like the combat we'll get into it
it is a dance battle but it's also great
and fun and requires thought
but you know bean juice it's just a
little bit too cute
i mean this is coffee if ever i've seen
it
you know you know
you just it's a bit it laying on it a
bit thick
what what did i just say i think i said
land on it a bit thick
what does that mean a lot of alana howdy
doody looking for a bun i am always
looking for bonson
oh no sorry i'm not actually look at
these little cuties
i would like to capture you and enslave
you for life
all right taffy don't touch me
okay oh well it worked out they told me
to [ __ ] off so
that's the ideal okay this is where i
pick my ooblet club which is basically
where i'm going to pick my starting
pokemon
[Music]
is this soundtrack on spotify let me
just check that real quick
it is apparently by pedro silva
hell yeah dude
good stuff these are our local oobleck
club leaders i thought i'd get
let them each give you a quick pitch to
see what they're about okay
the front buns are delightful
am i a sweet cutie who loves cute things
no but also that's not even cute it's
that's not cute i don't whatever peak
snobs don't do pitches you should be
pitching to me all right basil damn
a club one of leaders strong competitors
and just generally successful people
i i also don't really you know
i'm not picking up your vibe your weird
beetle
i don't really know what to say about
memphins or what to do with my hands a
club for clever people who aren't very
good at social interactions
that's the one i picked the first time
because i feel like that fits me but
also because i love the
astronaut vibes and i do think sideki is
sort of cute despite having
the worst name if you like adventure the
outdoors in nature you should join me at
the moss sprouts you're a stupid hippie
and i hate that about you
and i would not consider myself a woodsy
outdoorsy type but i do
love shrubber we're back to the start
we'll go on shrombo i'm going to become
a hipster i'm finally
committing thank you i can't wait i
appreciate that
you really walked out of portland oregon
rare not huh you know you just
everybody in the pacific northwest just
really loves
red so i guess i have to commit to
wearing played now but i got this cool
mushroom huh
now that you've got an uber you should
try getting it into a dance-off that is
all i've ever wanted to do
i thought you'd never ask let's do it
let's do our first dance off yeah i
screw you lump stuff
a little twerp or whatever
hang on hang on i'm going to make it
look like i'm one of the crab
[Music]
i feel like i'm off tuned with the rest
of them but it's because they sort of
jump out of rhythm so it's like jump
jump
cross side side what is this
choreography you got someone that'll
loot me and i look like an idiot
okay each turn you draw random dance
moves for you to choose from
correct i do um okay how many points do
i have right now we got three
they don't have three points so that
would be stupid no i take it back i
don't want to use it
[Music]
like oh let's do the shake it then if i
if i can do that i'm shaking let's do it
ah i'm not even with the crowd now damn
it ah they keep moving you know
uh end time
[Music]
what do you think you're gonna beat me
with that this one point vibes you dummy
i'm just gonna use the shake it again
six points is a lot of points dude
one beat do we have anything plus one
yeah let's do this too
i killed that we're on 14 we have to get
20. this dude's on two
[Music]
easy gg easy
um i have three now i could do that flip
floss i could get that
seven points to win
yeah i'm so proud of you little mushroom
i'm so proud of you
[Music]
can you tell that i basically haven't
hung out with a real human in months
but what gave it away yes lump stump i
will take your seed
thanks bro yeah so basically you can
plant the seeds to like i think it makes
you grow other ooblets
um we'll get to the farm in a bit
[Music]
yeah give me that seed seeds
i was making a sex joke but then i
turned it into final fantasy 8 reference
it's lay it i will head to my farmhouse
now and get settled in thank you maya
tinstol
you gay as hell this feels like a game
that i should maybe be playing with the
controller let's do that let's jump to
controller shall we
here's my farmhouse not great
you're right house is
sort of a way to describe it okay that's
fair
i would take a bad house for free would
i
because then you have to pay for upkeep
maybe is that a bad financial investment
is it better to have a bad house
than to have no house
probably all right mead god damn doc
fine brought me a couple of things to
get me started with my phone great
a sweet root vegetable which can be used
to create fruit toast
okay cool basic scraper i need that
give it a shot just don't dig deeper
than six feet down anywhere around here
this whole lady been killing people is
that what just happened
are you trying to tell me they're even
out here is this where you
keep the bodies oh i should stop being
mean to her